daily wire Oath Keepers founder Stuart
Rhodes received the longest prison
sentence to date stemming from the
January 6 2021 riot at the U.S Capitol
convicted by a Washington DC jury in
November on seditious conspiracy and
other charges the 58 year old Rhodes was
sentenced on Thursday to 18 years behind
bars I dare say Mr Rhodes and I never
have said this to anyone I've sentenced
you pose an ongoing threat and Peril to
our democracy and the fabric of this
country said District Judge Amita Metta
according to CNN
uh I think it's interesting if the judge
says I've never said this to anyone you
pose an ongoing threat really yeah
that's exactly the problem your honor
is that you've never said that to anyone
until this person
who was involved in the January in
January 6th
uh I I'm I'm willing to bet that you
have encountered uh as a judge and you
have presided over trials
many times of criminals who absolutely
pose an ongoing threat to this country
into the fabric of our society every
violent Criminal
every chronic violent criminal and so
many violent criminals are are chronic
um in that they continue in this
behavior and will always continue as
long as they're allowed to all of them
pose an ongoing threat it is a threat to
the fabric of our society which is right
now right now being ripped at the seams
by by crime
uh but she's never said it to anyone
before
never said that to anyone before uh
until this person
who who by the way is not an ongoing
threat
January 6th is over
okay it's it's been over for a long time
it's not ever going to happen again I
think that's pretty clear
and anyone involved does not pose what
threat do they pose
really this person let's say Stuart
Rhodes is an ongoing threat to our
democracy how so
let's just say you let Stewart Rhodes
walk out free and he's free tomorrow
what is he going to do to our democracy
what is Stuart Rhodes going to do to
destroy our democracy single-handedly
picture the perfect Summer Night the
warm breeze on your face as you Lounge
in your favorite chair outside the grill
is sizzling with Juicy Burgers the aroma
of the food is irresistible and your
mouth Waters as you wait for it to be
cooked to Perfection now imagine what
this perfect summer night would look
like if you went to turn on the grill
and your propane tank was empty that's
where my friends at cinch come in cinch
is a propane grill tank Home Delivery
Service they deliver propane tanks right
to your door cinch delivers on schedule
and they don't require any long-term
commitment or subscription plus delivery
is completely contactless you don't have
to wait around at home you can track the
order on the Cinch app from anywhere
whether you're grilling for the sweet
baby gang camping with your family or
lighting up your fire pit on a cold
summer night cinches propane delivery
service ensures that you have the fuel
you need to make the most of every
moment go online to cinch.com or
download their app to order new
customers can get their first tank
exchange for just ten dollars with promo
code Walsh that's
cynch.com promo code Walsh this is a
limited time offer and you must live
within a cinch service area to redeem it
visit cinch.com offer for details are
you tired of breathing in polluted air
in the comfort of your own home and want
to safeguard your family's health and
well-being well with our friends at
Enviro cleanse you'll never have to
worry again Enviro cleanse is an in-home
air purifying unit designed to destroy
cold and flu viruses allergy and flaming
toxins mold and even more uh with Enviro
cleanse they promise far fewer colds
allergies and better sleep they even
give you a free air quality monitor to
test the difference in your home if all
um home purifiers are the same then why
did the US Department of Defense select
Enviro cleanse to protect and purify the
air on board our Navy ships Enviro
cleanse air purifies uh air purifiers
have a hospital grade technology their
air purifiers come in all sizes all
colors and prices to fit every budget
they offer additional products like
Surface Cleaner and laundry detergent as
well you can get all of it there breathe
in pure air and live a healthier life as
well visit
ekpure.com use code walls for 10 off
your Enviro cleanse home air
purification unit right now you also get
their free air quality monitor plus fast
free shipping that's a 150 savings which
you can get at ekpure.com code Walsh
that's EK pure.com promo code Walsh you
know uh
this is this person has the longest
sentence of any of the uh the January
Sixers and uh all we know that all of
this is politically motivated of course
and uh the 18 years is absurd and unjust
it is this is a cruel and unusual
punishment it's really it's
unconstitutional
for that reason
um
but I could almost
in a different world you know in like
some kind of we talk about living in a
fantasy world in a fantasy world
the way that they've come down on people
involved in January 6 giving them these
long prison sentences
there is there is a a possible universe
where I could maybe be okay with some of
that and that would be a universe where
we live in a country with a with a
actual criminal justice system
that comes down on crime partially and
severely
um
and where you know violent criminals are
locked away forever
and we actually execute people and not
after 30 years on death row
and we do things like we execute drug
traffickers
you know in a country where we take
criminal justice that seriously and we
are that consistent about it
um
and we are that severe with criminals
in that kind of country then
yeah maybe they say well look if you if
you participate in a riot we're gonna
put you in jail for 20 years if you
participate in a riot
I could be okay with that
as long as again it's in the context of
Criminal Justice System where they take
all crime seriously and also they do
that with all rioters so the BLM rioters
if they were all looking at 20 30
40-year prison sentences
and then January 6 comes along some
people on the right participate in a
riot it was a riot
and they say well same thing's gonna
happen to you
no exceptions it's paying right you go
to jail for 20 years
I'd be okay with that I'd be okay with
with you know if the if the standard was
you participate in a riot you're in jail
for 20 years
that's it
certainly make all riots go away
and if that was the world that we lived
in and uh there was a riot and there was
people on our side allegedly involved in
it then I would say well
you know that's this those are the rules
but we don't live in that world that's a
fantasy world we don't live in that
world uh we live in a world where if you
participate in a riot on the left then
nothing happens to you you could go and
burn down a police station you could
kill people you could throw bricks at
the you know you could bash police
officers over the head with bricks set
police cars on fire nothing happens to
you
you can have violent criminals who have
been arrested 40 times that are still
walking the street assaulting old ladies
all that is allowed to happen
and then January 6th and that's the one
time that the criminal justice system
decides to get really serious about uh
about
punishing crime
and that'll do it for the show today
um as we head into the weekend and there
won't be a show on Monday I believe
because Memorial Day so I'll talk to you
on Tuesday have a great day Godspeed